[Music]
I'm her dad and she's beaming with
happiness that means more to me than
anything that's what I want Molly to
look like happy she confirmed in the
Billboard magazine that she was engaged
to Liam which they haven't really spoken
about it before are you excited about
having a better son-in-law man leaves a
great guy I don't know what their future
plans are I'll like think I'm confirming
is my name is Billy Ray Cyrus maybe
that's the only thing I know Billy Ray
you're so fun let me check this liam is
a great guy like man I like hot I like
his heart yeah oh he's got a great
spirit about him I'll tell you something
you don't know about him though what
he's a great artist as a payment really
have you ever seen his art no me neither
and often sudden I go into this room and
there's like a thousand five hundred
paintings of like these things I'm who
did all this stuff
Liam paints a real what is your next art
show and he's very humble yeah about it
well really I don't know you know I
don't ever tell I'm like dude what are
you talk
he's got painting after painting and
that's just incredible stuff Wow he's a
painter who do do you guys get with all
your busy schedule do you get time to
hang out with him alive we've been
hanging out more I'd say in the last
couple months than the last couple years
it's been a really really great time
period there's something um full circle
if you will maybe about our family and
our lives and looking at it now and
saying well okay what actually happened
here
[Music]
you
[Music]